.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ein Drittel der Bevölkerung
hat einen Migrationshintergrund.
Diese Realität müsste sich
in der Politik widerspiegeln.
D.h., dass es
eine Selbstverständlichkeit wird,
dass sich Leute mit
Migrationshintergrund einbringen.
Im Juni bekam ich
den Schweizer Pass und sagte:
"So, jetzt geht es los!"
Und es ist wirklich erstaunlich:
Mich haben viele
ausländische Organisationen,
migrantische Organisationen
unterstützt.
Als ich gewählt wurde,
sagte ein Freund zu mir:
"Erinnerst du dich?"
"Als du in die Schweiz
gekommen bist, hast du gesagt,
dass wir unsere Beziehungen
zu dieser Gesellschaft
entwickeln sollten."
Das habe ich geschafft.
Als Zugewanderten interessieren mich
die wenigen gewählten Migranten
in der Schweizer Politik.
Ich möchte von ihnen erfahren,
was sie dazu bewogen hat,
sich der zeitintensiven Politik
zu widmen.
Ich entschied mich für drei Politiker
auf kantonaler Ebene,
die alle als Flüchtlinge
in die Schweiz gekommen waren.
Durch diese Erfahrung
sind sie in einer besonderen Weise
für die Politik sensibilisiert.
In Basel begleite ich Sibel Arslan
zu einer Grossratssitzung.
Sie kam als Elfjährige aus einem
kurdischen Dorf in die Schweiz.
Sibel lernte zunächst
in einer Sonderklasse Deutsch.
Später studierte sie
Rechtswissenschaften.
Ich bin seit 2004 in der Politik.
Ich bin auch seit 2004
Schweizer Bürgerin.
Ich liess mich einbürgern und fand,
ich müsse irgendwie lernen,
wie das politische System
in der Schweiz funktioniert.
Ich erkundigte mich,
wo ich mich engagieren könnte.
Ich entschied mich für meine Partei:
BastA! - Basels starke Alternative,
die zu den Grünen Schweiz gehört.
Ich ging ins Sekretariat und sagte:
"Hallo, ich bin Sibel Arslan."
"Ich würde gerne
bei den nächsten Wahlen mitmachen."
"Was muss ich tun?"
Sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin,
Frau Statthalterin,
meine Damen und Herren ...
Sibel Arslan
setzt sich an diesem Sessionstag
für Spielgruppenleiterinnen ein.
Diese seien wichtig
für die Sozialisation
und Sprachförderung der Kinder.
Sie brauchten deshalb
mehr Anerkennung.
... dann kommen sie
auf einen Stundenanteil
von etwa 12-18 Fr.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht fair,
diese jungen Frauen auszubeuten,
die sich sehr engagiert
für ihre Arbeit einsetzen.
Ich glaube, das müsste man
anderweitig unterstützen.
Deshalb wäre es wichtig,
dass sich der Kanton
viel stärker finanziell beteiligte.
Herzlichen Dank.
Ich wusste nicht,
wie man einen Vorstoss vorbereitet -
wen man in der Verwaltung anruft,
welche Abteilung zuständig ist,
welche Personen in welchen Parteien
man ansprechen muss ...
Diese Strukturen zu verstehen,
hat mich und alle anderen mit Migra-
tionshintergrund Jahre gekostet.
(Frau) Das Abstimmungsergebnis
lautet 39:39 bei einer Enthaltung.
Ich entscheide mich auch hier
fürs Stehenlassen.
Ein kleiner Erfolg ist erzielt.
Das Geschäft
wird wenigstens nicht abgeschrieben,
sondern weiterverfolgt.
Rupan Sivaganesan,
Sohn tamilischer Asylsuchender,
sitzt seit 2006 im Zuger Kantonsrat.
Seine überraschende Wahl
erregte damals schweizweit Aufsehen.
Er war der erste Farbige
in einem Kantonsparlament.
Ich habe in Sri Lanka
das Untergymnasium besucht.
Ich kam mit 15 hierher.
Das war für mich ein Kulturschock.
Einerseits sah ich, dass in der
Schule alles verpasst, vorbei war.
Mit 15 hat man
die Regelklassen verpasst.
Zweitens, was mich
auch z.T. traurig gemacht hat:
Sri Lanka ist
trotz des 30-jährigen Bürgerkriegs
immer noch ein Bildungsland.
Bildung ist immer noch sehr wichtig.
Da habe ich ... Ein grosser Teil
der Tamilen, auch mein Vater,
ist im Gastronomiebereich tätig.
Oder in der Reinigungsbranche.
Das hat mich etwas traurig gemacht.
* Feierliche Orgelmusik *
(Mann) Liebe hier anwesende
Politikerinnen und Politiker:
Sie sind bereit
für Ihre Vereidigung.
Ich meine, Sie können
die Regierungsverantwortung
nur gemeinsam tragen.
Und Sie werden, das sage ich jetzt
als katholischer Pfarrer,
die Hilfe des Heiligen Geistes,
die Hilfe des Geistes Jesu Christi,
der uns vom Vater gesandt wurde,
brauchen können.
* Feierliche Orgelmusik *
Es ist für mich als frisch gewählten
Kantonsratspräsidenten
eine grosse Ehre
und ein bewegendes Erlebnis,
in diesem Gotteshaus
mit der Vereidigung
meine erste Amtshandlung
vorzunehmen.
Ich bitte Sie,
geschätzte Kantonsrats-
und Regierungsratsmitglieder,
die Schwurfinger zu erheben ...
... und mir die Worte
"Ich schwöre es" nachzusprechen.
Ich schwöre es.
(Alle) Ich schwöre es.
* Feierliche Orgelmusik *
Ich kann mich schon erinnern,
v.a. auch die Farbe ...
Es gab eine neue Farbe
in unserem Alltag.
Rupan ist eine Bereicherung
für den Zuger Kantonsrat.
Er bringt lebensnahe Vorschläge.
Ich finde auch, dass er für die
Migration oder die Immigration ...
Es ist gut, dass sich auch Leute,
die zu uns gekommen sind,
engagieren
und in die Politik einsteigen,
und damit
eben auch einen Mehrwert bringen.
Rupan, in einer hinduistischen
Familie aufgewachsen,
möchte Kirche und Politik
strikt trennen.
Er lässt sich mit wenigen anderen
im Ratshaus vereidigen.
(Ratspräsident) Ich bitte
die gelobenden Kantonsrats-
und Regierungsratsmitglieder,
ohne Erheben der Schwurfinger
mir nachzusprechen:
Ich gelobe es.
(Alle) Ich gelobe es.
- Danke.
Rupans Politkarriere begann im
Kantonsrat bei den Grün-Alternativen.
Er wurde jedoch sechs Jahre später
überraschend
aus der Fraktion ausgeschlossen.
Heute ist keiner mehr willens,
über diesen Konflikt zu sprechen.
Schliesslich arbeiten sie
im Rat wieder zusammen.
Nach Anhörung beider Seiten
hatte ich den Eindruck,
dass es wohl die Konkurrenz
mit anderen Fraktionsmitgliedern war,
die zu diesem Ausschluss führte.
Interessant dabei war,
dass die Partei
den Ausschluss des einzigen Migranten
gegen aussen
lange nicht kommunizierte,
weil keiner
als fremdenfeindlich gelten wollte.
Heute ist Rupan bei der SP.
Tharsini Mangalarupan kam als Kind
aus Sri Lanka in die Schweiz.
Die gelernte Krankenschwester
arbeitet als Teamleiterin
in einem Pflegeheim.
Sie erwirtschaftet
das Haupteinkommen der Familie
und unterstützt ihren Mann
bei seiner politischen Arbeit.
Ich lernte ihn
im sozialen Verein kennen.
Er war damals schon sehr engagiert.
Er ist ein Mensch, der sehr gerne
hilft und sehr hilfsbereit ist.
Darum staune ich nicht, dass er
auch jetzt noch sehr engagiert ist.
Das finde ich schön, und ich bin
auch ein wenig stolz auf ihn.
Nur ein wenig?
Dank meines Hintergrunds
habe ich vielleicht
einen anderen Blickwinkel.
Ich betrachte vieles anders.
Und ich habe irgendwie
eine gewisse Lebenserfahrung.
Ich weiss, was es für einen
Flüchtling an Schwierigkeiten gibt.
Ich weiss,
was die Schwierigkeiten sind,
wenn man in dieser Gesellschaft
die Sprache nicht beherrscht.
Seine Motivation für die Politik
schöpft er aus der eigenen Erfahrung.
Sein beruflicher Einstieg
war alles andere als einfach.
Sehr lange suchte Rupan
eine Lehrstelle,
bis er dank Vermittlung einer
Schweizerin eine als Drucker fand.
Zurzeit studiert er
an der Fachhochschule
für Soziale Arbeit in Luzern.
Eines wusste Rupan genau:
Er wollte nicht das ganze Berufsleben
in der Küche arbeiten
wie viele Tamilen.
Er hatte andere Ziele
und suchte Kontakte ausserhalb
der Gemeinschaft seiner Landsleute.
Ich habe
integrative Vereine ausgesucht.
Integrative Organisationen.
Da sind Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
dabei, da sind Albaner dabei,
da sind Afghanen und Iraner ...
Es ist wirklich
eine gemischte Gruppe.
Dort diskutieren wir, woran es
uns fehlt und was wir tun müssen.
Hasim Sancar ist einer der wenigen
Migranten der ersten Generation
in der Schweizer Politik.
Als der Kurde vor über 30 Jahren
in die Schweiz flüchtete,
erkannte er früh,
dass er über den Kreis der Landsleute
hinaus Kontakte suchen sollte.
Er sitzt seit drei Jahren für das
Grüne Bündnis im Kantonsparlament.
Zuvor war er sechs Jahre
im Stadtparlament Bern.
Ich treffe ihn
im Büro von Pro Infirmis,
wo er als Bereichsleiter tätig ist.
Was würdest du jemandem empfehlen,
der frisch
in die Schweiz gekommen ist
und der hierbleiben will?
Sofort anfangen!
Nicht warten! Sofort anfangen!
Auch wenn Misserfolge vorkommen:
wiederholen,
weiterfahren, dranbleiben!
Weiterfahren, dranbleiben!
Wie war sein eigener Weg?
Der Weg war lang und steinig.
V.a. am Anfang
war es sehr schwierig,
einerseits wegen
der fehlenden Sprachkenntnisse,
v.a. Deutschkenntnisse.
Ich konnte ein bisschen Französisch.
Auf der anderen Seite
Qualifikationen und Fähigkeiten,
die man mitgenommen hatte,
die hier nicht gültig waren,
wenn man das so sagen darf.
Kommt ihr?
- Ja, wir kommen.
Hasim Sancar
ist mit Annemarie verheiratet.
Das Paar hat zwei erwachsene Söhne,
die studieren.
Annemarie Sancar war acht Jahre
im Berner Stadtparlament.
Ein Jahr
amtierte sie als höchste Bernerin.
Wie beurteilt sie den politischen
Werdegang ihres Mannes?
Hasim hat Erfahrungen gemacht
von Diskriminierung,
auch von Ausgrenzung und Armut.
Er kommt aus Kurdistan.
Dinge,
die wirklich lebensprägend sind.
Wichtig ist, dass er seine Politik
immer wieder auf die Frage
Diskriminierung, Grundrechte,
Rechte für alle zurückspiegelt.
Was er auch ...
In welchen Themen er auch aktiv ist,
er hat eine grundlegende Haltung
wie eine Art Folie oder ein Mass,
in dem er seine politischen
Forderungen widerspiegelt,
sei das jetzt Finanzpolitik,
sei das Sozialpolitik.
Es geht ihm letztlich immer
um soziale Gerechtigkeit.
Und da, glaube ich,
ist er viel konsequenter
als viele Politiker hier.
Wir waren gestern im Kino
und haben diesen wunderschönen Film
von Kappadokien gesehen,
den dreistündigen.
Wie heisst er?
- "Winter Sleep".
"Kış Uykusu".
Wir kamen spät nach Hause -
wir waren mit Caroline Benz
noch was trinken.
Dann fing Papi um Mitternacht
noch an, Köfte zu machen.
Und weil er so müde war,
wurden sie immer grösser.
Da musste er wieder kleinere machen.
Das hat nichts mit Müdigkeit zu tun.
Je länger es dauert,
desto grösser macht man sie,
damit es nicht mehr so lange dauert.
In seinen ersten Jahren
in der Schweiz
interessierte Hasim Sancar,
was in der Türkei politisch geschah.
Er kämpfte v.a. gegen die Menschen-
rechtsverletzungen in seiner Heimat.
Heute setzt er sich aber auch
für die sozial Schwachen
und für Umweltthemen
in der Schweiz ein.
Guten Morgen. Internationaler Tag
der Menschen mit Behinderung.
Guten Morgen.
Internationaler Tag
der Menschen mit Behinderung.
Danke sehr. Schönen Tag noch.
Guten Morgen. Internationaler Tag
der Menschen mit Behinderung.
Danke sehr. Schönen Tag noch.
* Langsame türkische Musik *
Hasim Sancar hat mitorganisiert,
dass Vertreter
der Behindertenorganisationen
den frisch gewählten schweizerischen
Nationalratspräsidenten
Stèphane Rossini besuchen können.
Sie wollen ihn auf die Anliegen
der Menschen mit Behinderung
aufmerksam machen.
On va enlever le sac.
Peut-on parler en allemand?
- Parlez en allemand. Ça va bien.
Parce que nos collegues
parlent allemand. Donc ...
Ganz herzlichen Dank,
dass Sie uns heute empfangen
und Zeit für uns reserviert haben.
Ich weiss,
Sie sind schwer beschäftigt,
und die Ratsdebatten
sind sehr anspruchsvoll.
Es würde uns freuen,
wenn Sie das im National- und im
Ständerat verteilen lassen würden.
Aber Sie entscheiden.
Wir haben auch einen Brief.
Ich bin sehr froh,
dass Sie gekommen sind.
Das ist für mich wichtig.
Als Sozialpolitiker
ist mir sehr bewusst,
dass Menschen mit Behinderung ...
... im Leben
viele Schwierigkeiten haben.
Deshalb müssen wir als Politiker
uns immer engagieren.
Merci beaucoup.
(Alle) Danke. Merci.
- Merci, Monsieur.
Et puis on va coordonner ...
Was wohl seine Eltern sagen würden,
wenn sie ihn mit dem höchsten
Schweizer gesehen hätten?
"Gut gemacht."
"Schön, dass du dich
für die Anliegen der Menschen
mit Behinderung einsetzt."
Vielleicht auch ein Stück Stolz.
Aber vielleicht
auch etwas Bewunderung,
weil man mit dem höchsten Schweizer
einen Termin vereinbaren kann.
Und mit ihm, auch wenn es
ein kurzes Gespräch war,
zusammenkommt
und über ein Anliegen diskutiert.
Hier, ich habe was für dich.
Sibel Arslan ist gradlinig,
spricht auch das Unangenehme an.
Sie werde immer wieder
massiv angegriffen, sagt sie.
So z.B. Ende November 2014:
Sie hätte Leiterin
des Straf- und Massnahmenvollzugs
im Kanton Baselland werden sollen.
Sie machte
unter dreissig Bewerbern das Rennen.
Der Vertrag war schon unterschrieben,
aber es kam alles anders.
Ich bekam die Stelle.
Einen Monat später
rief mich die "Basler Zeitung" an
und fragte, ob es wahr sei,
dass ich diese Stelle antrete.
Dann wurde mir gesagt,
ich hätte Betreibungen,
man habe einen Auszug davon.
Aufgrund dieses Auszugs
würden sie darüber berichten.
Das machten sie dann auch -
etwa fünf Tage nacheinander,
ohne dass ich
Stellung beziehen konnte.
Aufgrund meiner Betreibungen
bzw. des Betreibungsregisterauszugs
lancierte man eine Kampagne.
Dann entschied
Regierungsrat Isaac Reber,
dass ich die Stelle nicht erhalte.
Fakt ist, dass gegen Arslan
Betreibungen liefen
wegen Bürgschaften und wegen eines
Unternehmens aus ihrer Studentenzeit.
Tatsache ist aber auch,
dass binnen Wochenfrist
alle Betreibungen erledigt wurden,
wie sie im Bewerbungsgespräch
ihrem zukünftigen Vorgesetzten
versprochen hatte.
Der Journalist
wollte das nicht zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Erstens brachte er nicht genau
das rüber, was ich ihm sagte.
Ich sagte ihm, die Sachen
würden sich gerade regeln,
mehr hätte ich dazu nicht zu sagen.
Zweitens sagte er auch noch,
dass eine Pfändung drohe,
was überhaupt nicht möglich war.
Denn ich war daran, meine "Schulden"
in Raten abzuzahlen.
Ich stand kurz vor dem Abschluss
der Rückzahlungen.
Drittens sprach er von einem Betrag,
von einer ganzen Schuld,
die extrem hoch war.
Das stimmte nicht.
Die Spekulationen
der "Basler Zeitung"
würden sämtlicher
Grundlagen entbehren,
sagte der grüne
Baselbieter Regierungsrat
und Sibels Vorgesetzter
Isaac Reber den Medien.
Die Zeitung spreche
von Schulden von über 60'000 Fr.
Tatsächlich
seien es lediglich rund 5'000.
Aufgrund der tagelangen,
negativen Berichterstattung
sei das Vertrauen in der Bevölkerung
aber zerstört worden.
Deshalb könne sie
die Stelle nicht antreten.
Die Öffentlichkeit hatte sich
mit falschen Fakten
eine Meinung gebildet.
Sibel Arslan selbst hat sich lange
öffentlich nicht geäussert,
weil es mit ihrem Vorgesetzten
so abgesprochen war.
Meine Anfrage für ein Interview liess
Regierungsrat Reber unbeantwortet.
Ich fühle mich in der Schwebe.
Der Schmerz hat etwas nachgelassen.
Es ist ein gewisses Schamgefühl da.
Muss man in einem Land,
in dem man nicht über Löhne spricht,
so über die Schulden und die finan-
zielle Lage einer Person sprechen?
Muss man jemanden
so nackt vor allen blossstellen?
Das finde ich ganz schlimm.
Mein Migrationshintergrund
spielte natürlich eine grosse Rolle.
Ich bin eine Bedrohung.
Ich bin ein Vorbild.
Ich ... zeige, wo die Grenzen
nicht aufhören sollten.
Einem Schweizer Mann wäre das,
was mir geschah, nicht passiert.
Zum Zeitpunkt meiner Recherche
waren von 15 kantonalen Politikern
mit Migrationshintergrund
nur zwei
in einer bürgerlichen Partei.
Diese kamen aber nicht
als Flüchtlinge in die Schweiz.
Migranten fanden bisher
eher bei den Linken Gehör.
Bei einer nationalen Karriere,
die sie anstreben,
hört der Migrantenbonus
auch bei den Linken auf.
Ich traf im Bundeshaus
die Luzerner Ärztin Yvette Estermann,
die seit 2007
für die Schweizerische Volkspartei
im Bundeshaus politisiert.
Wie hat sie in der SVP,
die eine nicht eben migrations-
freundliche Politik betreibt,
in so kurzer Zeit
den Weg nach oben geschafft?
Das weiss ich nicht.
Diese Frage
hängt immer ein wenig in der Luft.
Ich wurde das schon oft gefragt.
Ich weiss es nicht,
es ist schwer zu sagen.
Es ging mir immer um die Sache.
Es ging mir nie darum,
mich vorzudrängeln oder so.
Yvette Estermann kam 1994
durch die Heirat mit einem Schweizer
aus der Slowakei
nach Kriens bei Luzern.
Trotz Nachfragen
kann sie keine konkreten Gründe
für ihren Karrieresprung nennen.
Ihre schnelle Politkarriere scheint
ein einzigartiger Aufstieg zu sein.
Hören Sie in Ihrer Partei
manchmal Stimmen,
die Ihnen zu verstehen geben,
dass Sie nicht von hier sind?
Ja, das ist klar.
Das ist nicht nur unsere Partei.
Das geht über alle Parteien.
Es geht durch die ganze Bevölkerung
hindurch, dass einige sagen:
"Ja, ausgerechnet du!"
"Warum SVP
und warum Politik überhaupt?"
Das ist die Meinung
in der Bevölkerung,
dass sich Migranten
vielleicht zurückhalten
und das Feld
Einheimischen überlassen sollten.
Etwa ein Drittel der Schweizer Be-
völkerung hat ausländische Wurzeln.
Es ist anzunehmen -
das kommt sicher langsam -,
dass wir auch in politischen Ämtern
irgendwann einmal
zu einem Drittel Leute haben,
die in der zweiten oder dritten
Generation in der Schweiz sind.
Das ist meine Einschätzung.
Und ich bin auch überzeugt,
dass das eine gute Entwicklung ist.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen -
ich kam ja freiwillig ins Land -,
dass es vielleicht ganz anders wäre,
wenn ich hätte flüchten müssen.
Da organisiert man sich auch anders.
Deswegen sage ich,
dass ich grosses Glück hatte.
Dafür bin ich einfach dankbar.
Rupan Sivaganesan
besucht mit seinen Eltern
in Rubigen bei Bern eine
hinduistische Beisetzungszeremonie.
Die geräumige Mehrzweckhalle
eignet sich für die vielen Menschen,
die aus der ganzen Schweiz
angereist sind.
Sie wollen einer verstorbenen Tamilin
die letzte Ehre erweisen.
So sehr Rupan Sivaganesan
die Teilnahme der Migranten
am politischen Geschehen
in der Schweiz fördert,
pflegt er dennoch
auch seine kulturellen Wurzeln.
Er will seine Herkunft
nicht vergessen.
* Feierlicher Gesang *
Als meine Grossmutter
letztes Jahr in Sri Lanka starb,
war ich auch dort.
Ich fand es wunderschön,
wie man sich dort
von einem Menschen verabschiedet.
Dort kochte man jeden Tag das,
was sie gerne ass.
Hier in der Schweiz
ist das nicht möglich.
Man kann es in dieser Situation
nicht genauso machen
wie in Sri Lanka.
Aber man versucht hier,
diese Rituale,
diese Zeremonie beizubehalten.
Es schmeckt gut, nicht wahr?
- Ja, lecker.
Sibel Arslan trifft im Innenhof
des Basler Grossrats Edibe Gölgeli,
die seit Kurzem
im Grossrat politisiert.
Beide haben in der Schweiz
eine gute Ausbildung absolviert
und sind mehrsprachig.
Das sind Kompetenzen, die ihnen
Selbstbewusstsein verleihen.
... learning by doing.
Hattest du schon Themen,
für die du vorbereiten musstest?
Ich habe gerade eines.
Vielleicht gibt es heute ein Votum.
Basel spielt eine Vorreiterrolle.
Im Grossrat sitzen
sieben Personen aus der Türkei,
mehrheitlich
kurdisch-alevitischer Herkunft.
Auch ein FDP-Mitglied ist dabei.
Dank ihrer Arbeit hat Basel-Stadt
als einziger Kanton der Schweiz
die Aleviten, eine offene
Glaubensrichtung des Islams,
als Religionsgemeinschaft anerkannt.
Wenn ich an einem Ort lebe, kann ich
ja nicht immer nur zuschauen.
Was in meinem Umfeld passiert,
interessiert mich.
Ich kann nicht 40 Jahre hier leben
und sagen: "Ich bin eben Ausländer."
In einer gesunden Demokratie müssen
alle Gesellschaftsteile mitmachen.
Ich erlebte keine Diskriminierung,
also Ausländerfeindlichkeiten.
Vielleicht
ist es kindlich und jugendlich,
weil ich mein soziales Netzwerk
mit vielen Einheimischen habe.
Aber heute, als 36-jährige Frau
in der Wirtschaft -
als politisch engagierte Mutter
mit ausländischen Wurzeln -
finde ich, dass ich
viel mehr diskriminiert werde.
Das kannte ich früher so nicht.
Wir haben mittlerweile
sehr viele Leute
mit sehr etablierten Jobs
in der Privatwirtschaft -
vom Gesundheitswesen bis ...
V.a. im Gesundheitswesen ...
Ich wüsste nicht, was das Gesund-
heitswesen ohne Migranten täte.
Denn die leisten heute
sehr gute Arbeit.
Warum also nicht in der Verwaltung?
Wir haben in Basel
eine Integrationsbehörde.
Das ist also ... Dort haben wir ...
Die Kaderleute sind nicht Migranten.
Wir werden diese Themen
so lange bringen,
bis die Leute es
nicht mehr hören können.
Es ist wie beim Frauenstimmrecht -
man musste es immer wieder bringen.
Um die Wünsche unserer Wählerschaft
zum Parlament
bzw. zur Partei bringen zu können,
sollten wir in verschiedenen
Parteien vertreten sein.
Und zwar nicht nur
bei den Grünen und der SP,
sondern wie ich auch bei der FDP.
- Er ist von der FDP, ja.
Warum nicht auch CVP und SVP?
Wenn die SP sagt, die Umweltpolitik
sei für sie sehr wichtig -
dafür haben wir jemanden in Bern.
Oder:
"Sozialpolitik ist uns wichtig."
In Bern haben wir jemanden,
der für uns Sozialpolitik macht.
Wenn sie dann behaupten, die
Migrationspolitik, die Integration
oder Zugezogene
seien für sie auch wichtig,
sollen solche Leute
auch in Bern vertreten sein.
Es geht darum,
ob sie unsere Themen ernst nehmen.
Als die Glocke läutet,
eilen alle zu einer Abstimmung.
Beat Jans gilt als einer,
der Migranten in der Politik
gefördert hat.
Was sagt er zu dieser Kritik?
Ich teile diese Einschätzung nicht.
Man spürt schon
bei sehr vielen Interessengruppen,
dass die Erwartungen höher sind
als das, was man bieten kann.
Beim Ausländerstimmrecht -
wir lancierten in Basel
eine Initiative dafür.
Wir verloren brutal, sogar in Basel.
Dann ist es halt schwierig.
Es geht manchmal nicht nur darum,
ob man etwas will,
sondern auch darum,
ob man etwas schafft.
Wir haben so viele Migranten,
die angesprochen werden müssen -
sei das in der Bildung,
in der Gesundheits-
oder in der Sicherheitspolitik.
Da macht es Sinn, dass mehr
Migranten in der Verwaltung sitzen.
Für mich ist es wichtig,
dass die Migranten sich selbst
in die Politik einmischen.
Niemand kann sie so glaubwürdig
vertreten wie sie selbst.
Dieses Anliegen
habe ich immer vertreten.
Es ist wichtig, dass die Parteien
die Migranten auf die Listen nehmen
und ihnen die Möglichkeit geben,
gewählt zu werden.
Monsieur Sancan, c'est à vous.
Chère Madame la Présidente, chers
Messieurs conseillers d'état,
Grossratskolleginnen und -kollegen.
Stabile Lebensverhältnisse
und eine umfassende Integration
der Wohnbevölkerung
sind ein guter Massstab für den Weg,
den die Politik
der sozialen Sicherheit gibt.
Sicherheit heisst also
nicht mehr Ausgaben für das Militär,
sondern Solidarität
mit den schwächeren
Gesellschaftsmitgliedern.
Manchmal vergesse ich auch,
dass ich ein Migrant bin.
Ich bin dann
wie andere Kolleginnen und Kollegen
bzw. Gegner und Gegnerinnen.
Aber manchmal erinnert man sich
dann selbst wieder daran.
Oder man wird daran erinnert.
Indirekt - wenn man dann
angesprochen wird usw.
Wenn es Diskussionen
auf Französisch gibt,
vergesse ich auch,
dass ich ein Migrant bin.
Denn gegenüber Bernern
habe ich den Vorteil,
dass ich die französische Sprache
viel besser beherrsche
als viele andere.
Hasim Sancar
ist ein erfolgreiches Ratsmitglied.
Das Gute
an der politischen Arbeit sei,
dass er mit verschiedenen Leuten
im selben Saal sitze
und die Menschen
sich hier kennenlernen,
auch wenn sie verschiedene
politische Ansichten vertreten.
So könne eine Annäherung über die
persönliche Beziehung stattfinden.
Der Mensch ist ein soziales Wesen.
Er muss soziale Beziehungen
entwickeln.
Er muss sich austauschen.
Denn so lernt man voneinander.
Die Gesellschaft
ändert sich ja immer wieder -
das ist
ein nie endender Dauerprozess.
Nach der Grossratssitzung
gehen Hasim Sancar
und sein Ratskollege Fritz Ruchti von
der SVP gemeinsam zu Mittag essen.
Sie schätzen aneinander
v.a. die Offenheit und Ehrlichkeit.
Du hattest ja einen Bauernhof -
oder hast du ihn noch?
Also, ich ...
arbeite noch auf dem Bauernhof.
Wir haben
einen typischen Schweizer Bauernhof.
Also eigentlich im Flachland,
im Seeland.
Wir haben keinen Gemüsebetrieb,
sondern ganz allgemein.
Er beinhaltet Kühe und andere Tiere.
Auch eine Schweinemast.
Wir haben aber auch Ackerbau,
wir produzieren auch Saatgetreide
in unserem Betrieb.
- Was?
Saatgetreide.
Ich stamme ursprünglich auch
aus einer Bauernfamilie.
Ja.
Wir waren Selbstversorger.
Wir waren 20-30 Leute,
die von diesem Boden lebten.
Wir hatten alles: Butter, Käse,
Kartoffeln, Zwiebeln und Tomaten.
Hasim, was mich noch interessiert:
Du bist hier in der Schweiz,
kannst dir ansehen,
was z.B. in Syrien passiert.
Das mit diesen Islamisten,
mit diesen Extremisten.
Wie denkst du darüber?
Diese Härte, diese ...
... Brutalität - es ist schwierig,
einen Begriff dafür zu finden.
Das beschäftigt mich sehr.
- Ja.
Man liest es
fast täglich in den Zeitungen.
Da frage ich mich: "Was für Leute,
was für Menschen sind das?"
Die Dimension der Gewalt
der Dschihadisten
macht auch Hasim Sancar sprachlos.
Als Eingewanderter bewegt er sich
in zwei Welten. Ein Vorteil.
Welche Nachteile hat aber sein
Migrationshintergrund in der Politik?
Wenn man die geschichtliche
Entwicklung nicht miterlebt hat,
kann man natürlich
darüber lesen oder so.
Aber wenn jemand
das selbst miterlebt hat,
sieht er es mit anderen Augen,
als jemand, der darüber gelesen hat.
Aber auch Sprachen
sind z.T. ein Thema.
Denn es geht schnell,
und man muss schnell reagieren.
Auch schriftlich -
es muss ja fehlerfrei sein.
Sprache ist ein wesentlicher Teil
der poltischen Arbeit.
Nicht alles,
muss ich richtigerweise sagen.
Wenn ich dann aber
in türkischen Organisationen
oder Vereinen arbeite
oder in kurdischen
und alevitischen Vereinen usw.,
spielt nicht Deutsch
eine wesentliche Rolle,
sondern Türkisch oder Kurdisch.
Ich muss dann das,
was in der Schweiz passiert,
in der Muttersprache
erklären können.
In der Politik, im Rat
ist es natürlich wichtig,
dass man
die deutsche Sprache beherrscht.
Ich habe den Vorteil,
dass ich auch Baseldeutsch spreche.
Für mich ist der Inhalt wichtig:
Was bringe ich inhaltlich?
Sind es Inhalte,
die Hand und Fuss haben?
Der Inhalt
muss für mich einfach stimmen.
Ob die Grammatik dann
zu 100 % stimmt oder nicht,
ist für mich eher sekundär.
Obwohl ich jetzt schon
über 20 Jahre hier bin -
und ich denke auch auf Deutsch -,
gibt es gewisse Momente,
v.a. sehr emotionale Momente,
bei denen man einfach umschaltet.
Man denkt dann: "Oh, wenn ich das in
meiner Muttersprache sagen könnte,
käme es beim anderen
viel besser an."
Was haben meine Gesprächspartner
in ihrer mehrjährigen
politischen Karriere erreicht?
Einerseits habe ich erreicht,
dass sich die meisten Migranten
im Kanton Basel-Stadt
für politische Ereignisse
interessieren.
V.a. Leute aus der Türkei.
Mit kurdischem oder alevitischem
Hintergrund, aber auch nicht.
Dadurch, dass wir immer
einen direkten Austausch haben,
sind sie in Basel sehr aktiv.
Wenn man in der Schweiz
gesetzlich etwas verändern will,
dauert das lange.
Z.B. reichte ich meine Sprachmotion
2007 im Parlament ein.
Es gab eine grosse Diskussion.
Und jetzt ...
... 2013, 2014
wurde diese im Gesetz verankert.
D.h., es braucht so viele Jahre
nur für ein Gesetz.
Salam Aleikum.
- Aleikum salam.
Merhaba.
- Merhaba.
Hasim Sancar
besucht den Verein KUTÜSCH in Bern.
Die politischen Entwicklungen
in der Schweiz
seien für einige seiner Landsleute
zu komplex, sagt er mir.
Es sei aber
auch für viele Schweizer schwierig,
diese Inhalte zu verstehen.
(Türkisch)
Bei seinem Referat
vor wenigen Besuchern
wirbt er für die Umgestaltung
des Berner Breitenrainplatzes.
Die Schweiz ist bezüglich
des Ausländerstimmrechts
deutlich strenger
als vergleichbare Länder.
Die Folge ist,
dass gemäss Untersuchungen
das Interesse der Zugewanderten
für die Politik tiefer ist
als das der Einheimischen.
Ein Schweizer oder eine Schweizerin
bekommt mit 18 in der Regel
die Stimmunterlagen,
die Wahlunterlagen.
Diese Person
wird dann irgendwann einmal
den bürgerlichen Pflichten nachgehen
und sich an den Wahlen beteiligen.
Ein Migrant oder eine Migrantin,
der oder die
diese Unterlagen nicht erhält,
kann sich gar nicht einbringen
oder sich dafür interessieren.
Warum auch?
Warum sollte ich
das Ganze mitbekommen,
ohne dass ich
überhaupt angehört werde
oder man sich
für meine Meinung interessiert?
* Unverständliche Rufe, Lachen *
Hallo zusammen.
Tschau, Hasim.
- Salut, Hasim.
Sali, Hasim.
Gehts gut?
- Ja, danke. Dir auch?
Hallo, Hasim.
Nein!
Schnell!
Ja, hervorragend!
(Alle) Ohhhhh!
Hasim.
- Oh.
Der hat einen harten Kopf!
* Lachen *
Möchtest du hier auch noch?
- Hasim hat noch einen.
Nochmals?
Nein, du musst es umdrehen.
Die können sich jetzt
selbst kaputtmachen.
Ist gut, okay.
- Wer hat noch?
Nein!
(Türkisch)
Wer gibt Sibel Arslan die Stimme?
Ich muss
eine Differenzierung machen.
Meine Wähler waren nicht per se
Migranten und Migrantinnen.
Es waren sehr viele Leute aus
meiner Partei und aus Kleinbasel -
auch Schweizerinnen und Schweizer -,
die fanden,
dass auch Migranten und Migrantinnen
in die Politik müssten.
Es müssten junge Leute
in die Politik und auch mehr Frauen.
Sibel Arslan ist in Basel zu Hause.
Ihre ganze Familie
und der Freundeskreis leben hier.
Vor einem Auftritt
trifft sie ihre Freundin
Elif Yildirim zu einem Kaffee.
* Sanfte, orientalische Klänge *
* Stimmengewirr *
* Orientalische Popmusik *
(Türkisch)
Sibel Arslan ist
eine gefragte Podiumsteilnehmerin.
Hier im Forum für Zeitfragen
diskutiert sie
mit bekannten Persönlichkeiten
über die Zukunft der Stadt Basel.
Herzlich willkommen,
meine Damen und Herren,
hier im Forum für Zeitfragen
zum letzten Abend der Reihe
"Wie tickt Basel?"
Bevor ich weiterrede: Wollen wir
Mundart oder Hochdeutsch sprechen?
Sehr gerne Mundart.
- Mir ist es egal.
Gibt es viele,
die gar keine Stimme haben,
die in dem ganzen Konzert
nicht mitmachen können?
Ja, das sind all die Ausländer,
die seit Jahren in Basel leben
und nicht mitbestimmen können.
Sie können nicht mitziehen.
Das Wichtigste für mich
ist die Chancengleichheit,
dass man sich
auf Augenhöhe begegnet,
dass man das Gegenüber ernst nimmt
und die gleichen Chancen bietet.
Herr Kessler,
ausgeschlossen vom Konzert,
keine Stimme oder keine Möglichkeit,
die Stimme einzubringen -
sehen Sie das auch so?
(Mann) Das ist tatsächlich so.
196'000 Menschen leben hier.
Etwa 110'000
haben das Stimm- und Wahlrecht.
Das nutzt knapp die Hälfte.
D.h., bei Wahlen, Abstimmungen
sind es etwa 50'000 Personen,
die Politik machen.
Dann ist es 50:50.
Die Mehrheit, die gewinnt,
das sind etwa 26'000 Personen in
einem Kanton mit 196'000 Einwohnern.
Das sind etwa 15 % der Einwohner,
die die Mehrheit sind.
Das ist die ...
(Mann) ... direkte ...
... Demokratie, das ist sie.
Unsere Eltern und Grosseltern strit-
ten noch hart um Konfessionsfragen -
mit Vorurteilen,
die viel grässlicher waren als die,
die wir heute gegen Ausländer haben.
Sie haben das kultiviert.
Ich habe das als Junge noch erlebt.
Und wenn man diese Ehrlichkeit hat,
kann man auch Migranten
entsprechend aufnehmen.
Man muss sie nicht mögen, sondern
ihnen die gleichen Chancen geben.
Dann kann man streiten.
Man muss auch keine Fremdwörter
suchen, um miteinander auszukommen,
sondern einfach ehrlich sein,
aber mit gleichen Rechten.
Indem wir uns näherkommen,
können wir auch
Differenzen besser erkennen.
Wir müssen endlich mal ...
Das ist für mich das Anliegen,
wenn man von Integration spricht:
Wir müssen mit den schönen
homogenen Bildern aufhören,
als ob wir uns quasi
symbiotisch verschmelzen könnten.
Das wäre der Tod
von sozialen Beziehungen.
Hier lebt eine Gesellschaft ...
* Lachen *
* Stimmengewirr *
Ich gehe jetzt arbeiten.
- Gehst du wirklich arbeiten? Oje.
Toi, toi, toi.
Meine Heimat ist ...
Ich bin hier verwurzelt.
Ich denke ... unsere Heimat ist hier
und wird auch hier bleiben.
* Er stimmt die Gitarre. *
Rupan, was sind
die häufigen Nachnamen im Kanton Zug?
Landtwing, Müller, Meier ...
Was kannst du besser machen als
ein Herr Müller oder ein Herr Meier?
Äh ... Gute Frage.
Ich frage mich einfach,
ob man da ...
... diese Namen gewichten soll.
Ich habe genau wie alle anderen
1'600 g Gehirn.
Mein Gehirn funktioniert auch so.
Natürlich
ist der Hintergrund etwas anders,
aber es ist schade, dass man sich
auf diese Namen fokussiert.
Aber in Zug bin ich
der erste farbige Mensch,
der überhaupt
in zwei Parlamente gewählt wurde.
Das hat diese Offenheit gezeigt.
Aber trotzdem -
diese Diskussion gibt es:
Wenn es um Lehrstellen geht,
wenn der Name auf -ic endet,
hat man Mühe.
Wir trauern hier und heute
um die Hunderten von Verstorbenen
vor Lampedusa.
Wir trauern hier und heute
um die Tausenden
von Ertrunkenen im Mittelmeer.
* Melancholisches Lied *
(Chor) # Going home.
# Going home.
# I am there ...
# ... with you.
Hasim Sancar an der Demonstration
zum Weltfrauentag.
Ich fragte
den engagierten Sozialpolitiker,
ob es einfach sei, eine gerechte
Gesellschaft zu erreichen.
Ja, das ist eine philosophische
Frage: Was ist gerecht?
Aber ich denke ...
... es ist gerecht, dass man
eine gerechte Gesellschaft verlangt.
Dass man eine solidarische
Gesellschaft verlangt.
Wie viel man erreichen kann,
ist eine andere Frage.
Die Präambel unserer Verfassung
sagt ja:
"Die Stärke der Gesellschaft
misst sich
am Wohlbefinden der Schwächsten."
Ich denke, das ist ein Motto, das
wir uns als Beispiel nehmen sollten.
(Rednerin übers Mikrofon)
Wenn die Kantone
die längst fälligen Anpassungen
nicht vornehmen,
wird es Lohnklagen hageln.
* Stimmengewirr, Jubel *
Hi.
Sibel Arslan
in der Bar ihres Bruders.
Die familiäre Bindung
sei sehr stark, sagt sie.
Ça va?
- Nicht schlecht. Bei dir?
Mmh.
Ich bin in einer grossen Familie
aufgewachsen,
in einer sehr schönen Familie.
Sehr glücklich.
Ich habe zwei Brüder.
Ich behaupte immer,
das sind die tollsten Brüder,
die es je gegeben hat.
Nein, ein Stück Zucker.
Kannst du nicht unterscheiden
zwischen Zucker und ...
... Süssstoffen?
* Ruhige türkische Musik *
Von den 8 Mio. Menschen
in der Schweiz
sind rund 3 Mio. Ausländer
und Eingebürgerte.
In den Regierungen und Parlamenten,
in der Verwaltung und den Gerichten,
dort wo vieles entschieden wird,
bildet sich diese Realität
aber nicht ab.
Die Schweiz und ihre Migranten
haben einen grossen Nachholbedarf.
Ich glaube,
ich bin sehr authentisch.
Das, was ich vertrete,
vertrete ich aus fester Überzeugung.
Insofern werde ich bei den Themen,
zu denen ich mich immer wieder
geäussert habe, ernst genommen.
Ich möchte,
dass ich irgendwann einmal
als Schweizer Politikerin
angesehen werde,
nicht als Politikerin
mit Migrationshintergrund,
wo ich dann
in diese Schublade komme.
Das ist für mich sehr wichtig.
* Applaus *
(Frau) Und an fünfter Stelle ...
* Lauter Jubel *
Ich liebe Basel! Ich liebe Basel!
* Stimmengewirr *
He, Frau Nationalrätin Arslan.
- Frau Kollegin.
Ich gratuliere von Herzen.
Ich gönne es dir so sehr.
Das bedeutet für mich,
dass wir in der Schweiz
Geschichte geschrieben haben.
Wir konnten einen Sitz gewinnen.
Für Migranten, Migrantinnen,
für Linke, für Junge, Frauen
ist das ein Gewinn -
für unsere Stadt, einfach allgemein.
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich
J. La Micela, D. McMinn - 2015